[Music]
in a world where movie theaters still
existed
this disney at the top is bugging me not
just because this entire episode
symbolizes their relentless unabashed
desire to bastardize and conglomerate
every piece of content they have
but also because it doesn't even make
sense in the title it's not
disney's or even disney presents it's
just
disney like they slapped a literal
branding iron on it so their precious
cattle don't get rustled up by some
ragamuffin nerdwells
episode 4a may the verb be with you
near reading the opening crawl george
lucas is rolling over in his grave right
now
also stealing your movie concept from
lion king one and a half
on the desert planet of tatooine
capitalizing the word desert
no plans of leaving or getting involved
in any kind of intergalactic shenanigans
i believe you mean intergalanigans
rookie mistake
leave it to the pros who have been doing
this for like months that's right i said
months
plural the death star
[Music]
sounds creepy don't encourage the
narrator
bum bum bum wasn't written and therefore
should not have been narrated
never give the narrator improv powers
never
narrator then accidentally reads
parenthetical that says do something
funny oh
that's clever very meta oh wait am i
supposed to do something here
guys what do you mean by the word funny
tk582 i'm gonna need you to run these
numbers again
i took a third out of the budget already
show has the good sense to include jamie
heinemann and adam savage's voices but
not the sense enough to squeeze in a
sith buster's joke
i mean you laugh but two years later
this was literally the entire plot of
rogue one
also touching the back of the cd with
your bare hands or
pause it's work related
a conversation that every sins writer
eventually has with friends and family
somehow makes it into the show
also who would swim in that thing you're
just asking for all sorts of
rusting and chafing and material getting
caught in your pool filter
convenient gravity is convenient this
level of dewback training and womp rat
habitating basically makes phineas the
tiger king of tatooine and i am not okay
with that
rap breaks and kids songs this song is
basically the distillement of nostalgia
porn into a three-minute main line of
listing star wars references
strike that this whole episode is that
kind of nostalgia porn look i'm not
saying it's not working but you know
what else works
heroin ferb's below the nose strategy
with this helmet is completely unsafe i
bet he's a below the nose mask person
too
how hard is it to wear stuff properly
overstating your theme and thinking that
admitting it makes it all better in fact
i may have never even seen this if you
hadn't mentioned it you played yourself
pnf
you played yourself curse this show for
making me wonder where this creature's
bantha hole is located and whether or
not ferbin finn complicated its pooping
habits
check this out that one neighbor that
just can't help but show off all their
fancy
nobody asked to see your jaguar carl
just park it in the garage and stroke
your ego in private
if there's a better representation of
how ridiculous candace's neck
proportions are than seeing her in a
stormtrooper's outfit
i have not seen it someone get this girl
a neck brace cause she's a stiff breeze
away from complete spinal detachment
by chance was this droid distributing
socks of any kind man
unkar plute must have really let himself
go since his days as a storm trooper ceo
[Music]
this random coffee ad would be hilarious
if they actually did something with it i
was expecting some rick and morty style
interdimensional cable non-sequiturness
but instead it's just a quick name
jingle you couldn't even include a
tagline like
force brood for when you wanted a bit on
the dark side
technically we will not be drifting more
like violent ejection
belgian would be a trooper at tv since
not gonna lie
the death star flag is uncomfortably
similar to the greendale community
college flag
and now i can never unsee it it just
needs may the orifice be with you
printed on it somewhere and we're all
set
i can only go so long without giving the
show it's proper due for the consistent
width that brings us things like
tall darth and handsome that's a good
stuff right there
although shouldn't there be commas in
that store name teach the sarlacc to
brush his teeth
and giving a bantha a shower seems like
a waste of water to me
you know possibly a big deal considering
you're on a
desert planet wait till they discover
there's no girls on this planet
or boys or you know humans who don't
prioritize having a significant other
like it's the only thing that matters in
life
also show then proceeds to show us many
likely girls on this planet like her
or her or her or her or
her or her or her or
her see the mandalorian absolutely could
have used the back of this fortress to
get up to the top of this ship
[ __ ] platypus can do it he should
have and yes i'm sending mandalorians
child episode again here because i do
what i want
i have so many questions about this
bumper sticker first tatooine has a high
school
also only one jawa in this giant
workforce has an honor student and got
permission to put this on here and
finally are there even other vehicles
that would be following close enough to
be able to read it
so i guess three i guess i had three
questions what's cool is it when you run
the opposite direction on a conveyor
belt instead of just easily stepping off
to the side it's not prometheus
it's not rickon stark you know honestly
it's such a dumb thing to do i think
they forgot to even charter a school for
it
boy this show sure does play the hits
huh if you took out all the animated
recreations of actual moments from a new
hope
this would be like a regular length
episode a very confusing regular length
episode
and remember sam people travel single
file to hide their numbers
after yet another cheeky reference i'm
thinking this show winks at the audience
more than when deadpool went on laughing
to reenact the naked gun series i swear
you could just add wink
wink after half of these lines and it
really wouldn't change anything there
are many reasons to hate the tuscan
raider nation but the fact that they are
the kind of people to serve the cake
before opening the presents at a child's
birthday party
that's just asking for a mess icing a
cake that was just removed from the heat
means your icing melts into the cake
i watch reality cooking shows so i'm a
total expert at calling out your icing
bullsh
finifer is clearly using the special
edition version of my sizely and
honestly the five sins i'm about to give
are on the light side of what they
deserve for that choice
this text reads you got a joke no one
else did in arubash and not to get too
philosophical on you but if no one else
gets a joke is it truly a joke to begin
with i'd have the answer but i'm too
busy not hearing trees falling in woods
also in case you wondered the other two
say if you have paused this and
translated this into english
congratulations and
now go and press your friends to which i
say thank you and also you misspelled
annoy
it's like it's got a self-destruct
button what kind of idiot would design
that
still a better explanation than rogue
one though why can't i master this
considering you just need to turn your
head i actually don't know well someone
said he
shot first but i could have sworn it was
the other guy a wink wink
after the swimsuit and the hood ornament
this seductive singing marks the third
provocative use of these alien women in
sexy outfits
beginning to think i have a severe
twilight fetish wait i mean
the animators the enemies i'm beginning
to think the animators have a severe
twilight fetish
saved it my ship the centennial
chihuahua was on pace to finish the
castle run in 11 parsecs once again a
parsec is a distance not a measure of
time
but at least they won't try to shoehorn
some crazy retcon story about skirting a
black hole cluster into a movie four
decades later to explain it but that'll
never happen hitting the heavy bag
without any hand protection
i know the droids don't use gloves but
that's because droids haven't been known
to break their hands and pull their arms
out of their sockets i suggest a new
strategy wear some freaking gloves
when inspiration fails you and you
cannot reimagine the console of a
starship just add more gauges
more more continuing to blink your eyes
while frozen in the carbonator i mean
the carbonite these sexy stormtroopers
are apparently wearing corsets and this
is 100
not a sin for the sexy stormtroopers but
100 is a sin for them thinking they have
to put their bodies through that torture
to look sexy you're beautiful just the
way you are sexy troopers
serious trooper happy trooper
enigmatic trooper excitement i'm pretty
sure this convenient night just
unfroze at the most carbonenion time for
the plot
it appears as if proven squirts did
finally attend running school at the
hanna-barbera school of running in place
under falling things
but why would you save me wait how true
to star wars does this get because if
these two kiss
i may not recover i know we'll blame jar
jar
a wink wink oh we're allowing
modifications huh
give me a sec and despite ferb having
gone full evil darth maul
he does are you okay destroying the
machine that changed someone somehow
changes them back cliche
seriously if i microwave popcorn and
then take a baseball bat to the
microwave would it turn back into
kernels
actually would it you think maybe you
could turn this thing over
all the flies are rushing to my head i
think the whole point is that the blood
shouldn't really be rushing anywhere but
joke's got a joke i guess
this saxophone solo is not followed by
an episode of the simpsons apparently
there are still
copies of the death star plans out there
somewhere so still might have a teeny
problem there oh wink
they go around the block they come back
they go around again
they just go round and round for some
reason you all want to wear the cinema
synth pitchfork m on your body so we
slapped that
on some new merch and threw it in the
store posters hoodies tanks
socks click on the merch below the
youtube player or click the store link
at cinemasins.com
what about you guys we ain't found
you can ride back to the death star on
that bus pod what a piece of junk
hey patrick nice talk x marks the spot
may the force be with you and all that
stuff sweetheart how many times have i
told you don't say and stuff